hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and i don't know about you but i've
always been fascinated by the classics
by which i mean the good old classics
the works of ancient
western literature and philosophy and
thought
uh that are associated with both greece
and rome two thousand years ago
and more than that and fascinated in a
couple different ways on the one hand
i'd like them
uh on the philosophical or scientific
side i'm constantly referring back to
lucretius or aristotle or whatever
as part of the founding tradition of how
we think about the world around us
and i have on the literary side great
fond memories
of listening to audiobook versions of
the iliad and the odyssey
uh while taking long cross-country road
trips
but on the other hand there's also a
fascination because it seems weird that
those particular works
are given such attention in our society
right i once saw a two
cd collection remember there used to be
cds where you could put
data on so this one cd was all of the
works of ancient greek literature and
philosophy
and the other cd was all the works of
ancient latin literature and philosophy
and the point is that literally
everything that we have remaining
from that era can fit on two cds it's
not that much why are we giving so much
attention to so
tiny a corpus of work but i think
there's a reason
why we do that i think the classics do
have a special
role to play it's not an exclusive role
i think there's other things we should
be thinking about other than
the classics they don't offer all of the
answers but they were for our particular
uh cultural history the one that i am
embedded in
they were there first in some sense they
set the agenda in a very particular way
and we're still responding to them
that doesn't mean we should exclude
other classics i'm a very big
multiculturalist
in that sense we should of course pay
attention
to the classic works from other
traditions but we shouldn't neglect
the ones from the western tradition so
today in the conversation we have shoddy
bart
who is a classicist a leading classicist
at the university of
chicago and she has two books coming out
this year which are very very different
which is a wonderful book ending
to this conversation of the role of the
classics and the attention we should be
paying them
in the modern world one book is a
translation
of virgil's anaed uh she spells virgil
with an e
v-e-r-g-i-l she admits that other
people's fellow and i that's okay
uh the anaid is in many senses the
founding myth
of the roman empire as we talk about in
this
discussion it's sort of the roman
version of the iliad or the odyssey
but sort of a much more purposeful one
in
many ways and there are resonances
between
the anaid and modern politics modern
society
in both obvious ways and less obvious
ways so shoddy has translated
the anaid into a sort of not a
hipster valley girl idiom but a modern
way of talking that
really maintains the energy and strength
and vibrancy
of the original text so we talked about
why we should care about the unaided
what virgil had in mind what it means
for us today and then the other book she
has coming out later this year
is called plato goes to china and it's
about
how people in china today
think about plato and other western
classics
aristotle and the various poems and
plays and so forth
the chinese culture shoti taught herself
mandarin so that she could do this
project among other reasons the chinese
culture itself sort of
pays a lot more attention to its own
ancient texts its own classics
than we do here let's say in the modern
united states and so to some extent they
figure if you want to understand the
western mind you better read plato and
aristotle
right so she looks at how we can learn
about both
china and ourselves by thinking about
how this very different
culture interprets and makes sense of
and itself learns from
our classics so it's a wonderful
multicultural sort of
uh give and take and very much in the
spirit of the mindscape podcast where we
want to bring
different things together in a
disciplinary way and let the sparks fly
so let's go
[Music]
shoddy barge welcome to the mindscape
podcast sean carroll thank you so much
for having me
i want to start by asking a crazy
question have you ever uh
watched the british tv show morse
inspector morris or
its prequel series endeavor
now i've been thinking about how to
speak about the annea to you but i
didn't realize that
watching inspector morris might be a
prerequisite i haven't
what are you thinking of well i'm
thinking of it's a it's a detective show
but it's set in oxford england
and uh endeavour which is the prequel
show um is set
like in the 60s so a while ago and
there's a there's a time when there was
a
guy who was caught by the cops and
endeavor morse who was the main
character you know
uh who went to oxford and was an
academic star before he joined the
police force
says to the guy if you're going to
choose an alias don't pick the same
pseudonym odysseus used to fight
polyphemus
not in a town filled with classicists
and this made me think you know we don't
have towns filled with classicists
anymore that's that's the segway see
isn't that wasn't that good
because we're talking about here the
relationship of the classics to the
modern world i mean
as a classicist as a professional
card-carrying classicist
how do you think about like in the very
broadest picture
what role the classics have in the
modern world and let's put it this way
why did you choose to become a
classicist rather than all the other
academic things you could have done
that's two questions so let me answer
the first one first
and um it's a very complicated question
and it deserves a complicated answer
um our relationship to the classics and
in the western half of the world
is one that we increasingly don't see as
important we think of them as texts
written by dead white men
and often especially these days we are
critical of their ability to speak to
our values
or indeed to start any kind of
interesting conversation with
us as their readers this
is sad because it's uh fundamentally
incorrect for for many reasons um
the classics these ancient texts that
we're talking about
are classics precisely because in their
2500 year old history
people have read them differently
in every different era in other words
they've stood the test of time by
engaging in conversation with different
time periods and different cultures
and they can do the same with us they
don't have to stand for a set of values
that we repudiate
they don't have to stand for racism or
sexism
they what they do instead is they invite
us to enter into conversation
around those questions they invite us to
debate each other and to think
they might ask us what is justice but
they will never
tell us what justice is and it's
precisely this ability to be
pliant as i said that speaks to their
longevity
and i think we should understand that
they're still pliant
we can still do these things with them
so let me let me just hold in on that i
mean
is this a claim that you're making that
you would say is unique
to these particular western classics or
at
least
in the western canon it's unique to
these particular classics or is it
something that
they were there first so they sort of
laid the groundwork or
can we find similar things in all sorts
of literature or all sorts of works of
philosophy in the humanities
i would say that we can find similar
things in all sorts of works
especially those works that have been
around for a while
if we look uh for comparison
at say young adult novels that speak
directly to these
issues we'll find that while they have
valuable things to say
they don't invite us to think about or
question values they simply
tell us what the values are they simply
echo our present uh beliefs
but they don't ask us to engage in
discourse
around them the great classics of of all
cultures
not just western culture do sponsor
and encourage those kinds of discussions
and just to give you an example of how
pliant
these classics are to different kinds of
discourses and different eras
you can take for example the book i've
recently
translated virgil sinead
at the beginning of its reception it was
thought to be a work in praise of the
emperor
um by the time the early christians came
along
they thought it represented a very
sinful culture and that the classics
shouldn't be read at all because there
was sex and naughty gods and bad stuff
in them
not like the bible he has exactly
another classic um then some later
christians came along and said no no
you've misunderstood this is actually an
epic that's an allegory for the
christian everyman
and they went through anaes's life story
as being a
a christian set of rules for how to
behave
and then um what else um
following that you have a lot of
imperialists
especially in european history who look
to the poem and its tale of
expansion from troy to italy
and the start of an empire you have
imperialists who look at this and say
hey
this epic justifies imperialism and so
for example mussolini
in the mid-20th century took the unaided
as
proof that his new italian empire
should conquer the world and rule right
um and then during the vietnam war it
was seen as violently anti-war
and so today we can engage with it
ourselves and
have it ask of us questions that we
think are relevant
but we don't have to be trapped by its
reception history
that's why we don't condemn it yeah i
mean one of the one of the cool things i
think about this conversation is uh
we've been talking about this you have
two books coming out uh that i think are
are good because they're sort of two
very different ways
of encouraging modern engagement with
these classics one
like you just said a new translation of
the inaid is it anaid i'm going to
pronounce every single word in this
conversation
yes good uh and the other one is is
plato goes to china
about how the greek and roman classics
have been
received in china both both recently and
before
and so on the one hand you have a work
of literature and you
were translating it on the other hand we
have works of philosophy and how they
have a political impact
so uh these are both really cool and
they sound different and i think that
the the correct answer to sort of how to
mix and match them is just to talk about
both of them and we can see from the
sort of two ends of the spectrum what
lies in between so let's start with the
anaid some of us haven't read it
in a long time or ever so uh tell people
how it fits in because it's a it's a
roman thing it's not a greek thing it's
a little bit different than the iliad
and the odyssey but
related to them sure so the innate is
fundamentally
a story of the foundation of a
town in italy that would end up
leading to the creation of rome and the
dominance of rome
over the mediterranean in the um
augustine period
it was written by virgil under the
emperor augustus
who claimed augustus claimed that he was
in fact the
descendant of the trojan hero aeneas
and the plot of the story is that aeneas
escapes
from the burning ruins of troy after the
greeks have sacked it
and he takes a few people with him and
travels
over the mediterranean he knows the gods
have a plan for him but he's not sure at
first what the plan
is and eventually it becomes clear that
the plan is
he's got to go to italy he's got to
defeat the local italians in war
and he has to set up an empire there
he eventually invites the the italians
to join with him so it'll be a joint
trojan italian venture
but that only follows a very brutal war
he's lured along the way by various
temptations the most famous one of these
being queen dido of north africa who
falls in love with him and wants him to
stay in carthage and help her build her
empire
and he's having a jolly good time
staying with dido until
jupiter sends him a message and says get
the hell out of carthage you're supposed
to be found in rome
and so then he gets very scared and
continues on his mission
um and so there are moments in the poem
like this one where we see that in fact
the question of the god's authority and
destiny and so forth
is a little bit up in the air given his
druthers he'd stay
in carthage and
he has to be poked along to do his duty
it's not something that
is dear to his heart and the poem also
seems to suggest
that there are many possible outcomes
but this one
is the one we have to have it's a weird
thing because this is
something that we don't have at least
very explicitly in modern literature
this
idea that we are being nudged along by
the gods and i've never quite understood
what the relationship is supposed to be
in the classics between human volition
and what the gods want us to do
sometimes the
heroes resist what the gods want us to
do right that's true
um look i'm not going to touch the
question of volition versus the god's
will because it's way it's impossible to
answer
but i will say that when people were
talking about manifest destiny
in the mid 19th century in the u.s some
of them did
have recourse to the idea of the inaid
as the earliest version of manifest
destiny
anaya is told he has to carry out a
divine mission sorry aeneas is told he
has to carry out a
divine mission and to go west literally
and to subdue um the natives of a land
that doesn't belong to him
so it has been you know used as a
justification for such purposes that we
find
really distasteful today and to
contextualize it a little bit this is
written by virgil
um a few years bc right
and uh so this is when the roman
empire had just started right augustus
is sort of the first real roman emperor
i don't know i mean julius caesar i
guess counts but
uh augustus sort of codified things and
consolidated
so this is well after the greek epics
uh of the iliad and the odyssey by homer
and virgil is a person and we're not
even sure if homer was a single person
is that right
that is right so what is what is
tell us about homer a little bit just so
we we are thinking about this as
modern uh up-to-date classicists sure
well the homeric epics are essentially
epics centered around a heroic figure
right the iliad is about the rage of
achilles who's sulking in his tent and
won't join the fight
the odyssey is about the wily odysseus
who makes it home to ithaca
after the trojan war but loses most of
his men along the way
those epics are less concerned with
things
like foundation or civilization
or politics or the justification for
empire
which is what the inead seems to be so
the init is very different
in that a it's a political poem b it's
not written at the start of a
civilization it's written at the start
of an empire
augustus's empire but c it's
it starts to get written by virgil only
two years after
augustus comes to power in 31 bc
and we have to remember that um often we
look back with hindsight but virgil
didn't have the benefit of hindsight
so as he was writing his epic he didn't
know if augustus was going to be the
great guy who brought peace
or if augustus was just going to be
another one of these dictators and
generals who seized power briefly and
then lost it again
so um not only does he not write an epic
about augustus himself
but his epic about aeneas um
includes many hedges to let us know that
this is not a simple work of praise
and i'll give you some examples of those
hedges right
yeah uh so for example
he hints often in the narrative at
other versions of the story of aeneas
so that we're forced to remember them
and those other
versions of aeneas story say that aeneas
was in fact the traitor
who turned troy over to the greeks i
mean how is that for shocking
it's very strange that virgil would want
to remind us of this here and there
even though he's telling us a different
story about aeneas
um then there's the violent ending of
the epic
aeneas has been told by his father to
spare the defeated
but when his main italian enemy is
pleading for his life
in front of him with a huge wound in his
thigh
aeneas loses his temper and kills him
instead of sparing him and that's the
absolute last
line of the epic what an ending right
and the verb in latin for what he does
to turn us the stabbing of turnus with
his sword
is the same verb that opens the epic
where it means something
very different it means to found or lay
down
a city in a place the same latin verb
for both
things the idea fundamentally being you
put something into or on top of
something else
so the violence at the end recalls the
civilizational impulse at the beginning
of founding a city
and virgil seems to be reminding us that
you can't have one without the other
that
civilization is always predicated upon
an act of violence
right i find that very striking and then
there are other things he has his hero
sacrifice 12 italians alive and throw
them into the flames
um his hero occasionally lies
their suggestions that when the hero
talks about himself he's making it up
in other words there are constant
pushbacks to the main thread of the
narrative
and those pushbacks are there for us to
see and to understand
that we are meant to debate the values
of this epic and to ask
questions about things like empire
indigenous peoples missions what we
think about
god um whether or not
um one can ever justify these acts of
aggression and so forth
it's not a story that tells us what
values to have
it's a story that asks us what
what values might one have and why
yeah so that's very compatible with uh
what you said to give the sales pitch
for the classics at the beginning and
also probably
pre-figures what we'll be talking about
vis-a-vis plato in china in a bit but
probably some of our listeners don't
know about even the most surface level
much less the deepest level of this
so what would be like the most naive
high school level reading of the anaid
is it is it basically supposed to be
a pro-augustus pro-roman empire
propaganda piece yes
that's actually how it's been taken to
be for most of its
career as an epic over the past 2000
years um and when people complain about
the classics they're often complaining
about these kinds of values like you
know why should we be pro-augustine
but the epic that would be a very crude
reading of the epic indeed it would be
completely blind to the nuance of the
actual text
sometime hopefully soon we'll be once
again going out
traveling for work purposes and you know
what that means
expenses expensify is here to help if
you
like me or someone whose time is much
more valuable
than the time it takes to fill in
expense reports expensify makes it easy
for you to get paid back
expensify manages your expenses bills
invoices travel
and business corporate card spending all
in one place so you can focus your time
elsewhere you don't need to worry about
losing receipts you just take a picture
as soon as you get a receipt and you
toss it
better yet link your credit card and
expensify will auto match the receipt to
the expense
and submit the report for you
automatically to your manager controller
or
what have you if you have to travel for
work these days lots of supported
features for the modern day traveler
such as automatic international currency
conversion concierge real-time
notifications and mileage tracking
so visit expensify.com mindscape to get
started with a free trial
that's e-x-p-e-n-s-i-f-y
dot com slash mindscape
it's interesting because we had a uh
podcast uh
a couple years ago which i keep
referring to it was so good with edward
watts
who was a historian and we talked about
the end of the roman republic the
founding of the empire and various
you know political imaginations that
were going on i don't think we mentioned
virgil but this is part of any good
political movement right to have
um propaganda and and things like that
and i guess the case you're making is
that
virgil sort of did a little bit of that
but knew he was doing and also resisted
what he was doing while he was doing it
exactly and i would add one more
sentence he wanted us to
see that his version was one of
many possible versions that weren't
getting told right
right so he's not telling the story of
augustus's ancestor as a traitor
he's not telling a story of um
uh he's not telling one of the myths in
which aeneas never makes it to rome
right he is suggesting that
anaes was right to leave dido even
though
in the text that's put into question
dido thinks that they're married
aeneas thinks that they're just having a
hot affair yeah and
their two opinions are reflected in the
gods
juno thinks they're married and says
they're married and
venus thinks they're having a hot affair
so again even something like a woman's
perspective on the meaning of a
relationship
here is raised in book four
in the tumultuous days of carthage but
it's so it's an interesting choice for
on the part of virgil right i mean he he
is in this milieu where augustus is the
emperor were they friends did virgil and
augustus hang out
yes they were friends augustus became a
virgil's
sponsor as it were yeah and we know that
virtual red sections of the unaided to
augustus
but here's the thing he read sections
from books two four and six
we don't know what it was he may have
left out the ambiguous parts or the
violent parts
and again augustus had not been in power
that long when he started
nudging virgil to write an epic about
him
right and i think one of the ways in
which virgil hedged
was to go all the way back to aeneas and
to pick him as the topic
of the epic not augustus himself
interesting because in a prior work
virgil promises he'll write about
augustus's military triumphs
and he never does right so there's a
kind of pushback right there
yeah no actually that's what i was going
to ask about because you know it's an
interesting choice
when are pals with the emperor and you
want to do things the emperor
got to keep the emperor happy i presume
uh so writing an epic sounds good but
the aeneas stories were already there
right like he was mentioned
in the iliad as a character he he was he
doesn't come off very well in the iliad
but uh nevertheless uh julius caesar and
other members of the julian clan
into which octavian had been adopted
octavian being the future augustus
um nevertheless the the julians like to
claim descent from
venus through aeneas and through
aeneas's son
euless excuse me euless and you can see
the similarity between euless and julius
right so this was part of the julian
myth and then
virgil just comes along and cleans it up
a bit and makes a big story out of it
and this is a set of ideas that the
people of rome at the time would have
known about i have no idea how
i guess they weren't literate but they
were was there still sort of an oral
poetry tradition
telling these stories um they weren't
literate so this would be mostly for the
upper classes the senators
and the knights and the educated people
who support augustus needed right and as
his reign continued and as the peace
continued people
started believing that in fact he was
the great emperor that he portrays
himself to be and others have often
portrayed him to be
right right um so
there's a question of propaganda and
being aware of propaganda
there's also the the real good
things that augustus brought with him
they're also the terrible things
augustus did before he became augustus
when he was called octavian and people
often called him
a butcher for his violence in war
and in some sense virgil did not shy
away from
talking about the violence of war he did
not
and even his own hero as i said earlier
goes berserk
and do we have any sort of secondary uh
knowledge about virgil's opinion about
what he was doing in the
inea did he say like what his goals were
or anything like that
nope we don't do we have other people
who
you know i mean there must have been
courtiers or whatever well
very critical the we know that it was
used in the classroom
very soon after it was published oh and
we also know that
virgil maybe this is what you were
asking for virgil on his deathbed
asked for the anaya to be burnt
and a lot of people have scratched their
heads over time and said why did he want
it to be burned
one time for some people the answer has
been oh it wasn't fully finished
right because there are some half lines
in it i don't think that's the answer
i think he wanted it to be burnt because
he was worried it would seem like
pro-augustine propaganda and i think
history has borne him out
right right and is it so it goes back to
this beginning point about there is
something special about the classics how
there's some inherent ambiguity in them
they're not just didactically telling us
what to think um and you think this was
intentional
on virgil's part that he sort of wanted
to tell several stories at once
and uh leave it up to the reader or it
was did he think that
do you think that he thought that there
was a right reading of it
that's an excellent question i think he
just wanted us to
be aware that as propaganda if we were
going to take it that way
um it would have to be red with a very
large grain of salt
and he shows us why that is and his meta
message maybe
is beware of political narratives
because political narratives are
always ideologically charged right right
and i think we've seen a bit of that
um over the trump administration and its
political narratives
but it's also not even even with all
this in mind
it's much more than just a political
propaganda tract right i mean
it's there's love and uh emotions and
and games and
and things like that so virgil was
clearly enjoying himself a little bit
when he was writing parts of the poem
absolutely if you don't have a
complicated and rich narrative you're
not going to have a complicated enriched
text to engage with
right right so just going back to what i
said earlier if the message is too
obvious it doesn't make for very
interesting reading
was virgil explicitly trying to be the
roman version of homer
um his anaid does respond to the
iliad and the odyssey in various ways so
the first half of the aniod is about
traveling and the second half is about
warfare
and he often refers to episodes in the
iliad or makes
anaes seem like one of the heroes and
then like another hero
or he'll use similes from the earlier
poems but change them
yes so he's also very conscious that
he's doing a great work of literature
and responding to the greek tradition
how much time had passed between
uh what we think of as homer writing the
iliadine odyssey and virgil writing the
aeneid
people will debate on that but let's say
roughly 700 years
okay so that's like a huge amount of
time yeah
it kind of is it was already the ancient
world to
the romans of that time it was yeah we
lose sight of that don't we
and and i guess what i'm getting at is
what was the
picture of ancient greece two romans at
that time did they respect it did they
thought did they think that they had
surpassed it
or were they continuing it aha well you
know there was this
little saying by horus that greece after
being captured
by rome captured rome which means that
the romans were very much enthralled
to greek literature and greek culture
but didn't want to admit this
essentially so their first works of
literature were translations from the
greek before they started writing their
own literature
and this left them with a kind of
complex um
about um the value of their own works
vis-a-vis the greek works
right and so there was a competitive
angle
definitely in their relationship to
greek culture and literature
which they would often denigrate as
somehow being eastern
or not you know burly chested and strong
like the romans if you can say that
of literature um but which they um
which they competed with nonetheless i
mean in my mind
there's the iliad and the odyssey and
the unaided and like these are the three
big epic poems of the ancient world were
there competitors
to virgil were there other epics
floating around that these days we don't
give as much attention to
there were some earlier roman epics but
they exist in fragments
so basically um virgil came along
one won the prize of great epic the
other ones got lost and now we have
virgil
and it's not just that they happen to
get lost virgil was so popular there
were many copies of him so it was more
likely that he would survive right
precisely and is it you hinted at this
already
but um was the innate ever
lost in some sense or was it sort of for
the next 2000 years
um read and used in different senses
in european history it was read and used
in different senses
um so we talked a little bit about the
medieval view
that anae had represented a christian
everyman later in the middle ages
the tradition of anaes as the traitor
came roaring back
and there were novels or texts written
that
chose to focus on that tradition
um and later still
as you know it was read as an imperial
text or an anti-war text
and and so forth and so on so we've
always been engaging with it
yeah okay and it is i mean you mentioned
novels but i
something tells me that there weren't
really novels back then i mean i want to
move into the
question of you translating
the anaid i mean it's a it's a poem
right it's a huge poem so in some sense
you have to be a poet to do this is this
a
kind of intimidating thing or have you
been dabbling
and i made it even harder for myself by
laying down a number of rules
about what the outcome of my efforts had
to look like
so you know there are a lot of beautiful
translations of the innate out there
that's undeniable and i have my own
favorites too
but one difficulty with translations of
of latin
is that latin is very dense and english
is more diffuse
and so these translations of the anid um
would usually be about a third longer
than the
poem itself or they'd have much longer
lines of verse than the poem itself
and so the whole fast-paced action of
reading turned into a much slower
activity
changing the whole feeling of what the
epic was about in the first place
right so virgil has
six beats per verse i did not allow
myself to have more
more than six um um
i guess beats also although it's a
slightly different thing from the roman
beat
per line um virgil has
has a certain number of lines in the
poem i
made myself have exactly the same number
of lines so that there'd be line-to-line
correspondence
oh that's tough it was very tough virgil
relies
a lot on alliteration for poetic effect
i relied on alliteration virgil uses
simple language that sometimes gets very
dressed up in the translations because
they have to sound poetic
right i used very simple language and i
think the outcome of that
is a poem that feels very different it's
fast-paced it's action-packed
um you want to keep flipping the the
pages
somebody who read it said to me it felt
like watching an episode of 24 on tv
and that's that's um not the way we
we normally feel about reading the
unaided but you want that on
as a blurb on the back of the book
definitely when you start selling it i
haven't thought of that but i need that
as a blurb you're
absolutely right along with a picture of
what's his face uh
is it uh jack bauer yeah jack something
jack bauer yes him yes the that'll be
something
else of our day well you know but that
it was
also and this i guess there's another
question about how the audience would
have felt about this i mean homer's
epics
were absolutely there to be read out
loud right it was part of the oral
tradition it was the entertainment of
the day
was the innate also supposed to be like
that or was it already more hoity-toity
even when it was being written it was
um i don't know if i'd say hoity-toity
but it had a serious purpose
and because it was pressed into
educational use immediately
already under augustus um it never
really had a chance to be
entertainment okay and did you feel like
the
differences between being an epic poem
and being a novel right like it's not a
screenplay right it's not quite in the
modern
um uh vernacular or anything like that
so i mean
since you have come 2000 years later and
are used to
reading novels and seeing plays and
movies and so forth
did that color how you turned this poem
into something in english uh
not really because there's a sense in
which you can see
parts of the epic as in and of
themselves novelistic
so for example in books two and three
aeneas himself is speaking and he's
telling queen dido the story of what's
been happening to him you know the great
disaster
of his trip over the mediterranean from
burning troy
and in the in aid itself we have no
other corroboration for what he's saying
right it's just his story
so there's a sense in which we're
invited to treat it as fiction
rather than a true accounting to queen
dido
and the story is designed to be very
alluring it's designed to make
queen dido want to take care of him it
makes her
fall in love with him along with a few
pokes from the gods
um virgil makes us very aware of its
status
as alluring possibly fictitious
full of sea monsters and excitement and
travel and and crazy disasters and
skill and charities and so forth so
there's a sense in which it's a ripping
good yarn
but it's a yarn but is it is it too
crazy to say that some of the aspects
you're attributing it to it sound almost
postmodern
almost sort of meta-fictional um i think
it is meta-fictional
yeah it's about itself right it's saying
hey
an asus story is fiction it's up for
grabs i've manipulated it in a certain
way and hey the
innate itself is is there and it can be
manipulated in different ways
as we've seen happen to it so yeah i
would say it is meta fictional
not in a in a boring theoretical way but
in the way that it invites us to reflect
on it
right so this is this stuff that we
attribute to you know thomas pynchon or
charlie kaufman
in movies is is over 2000 years old is
what you're telling me
yes and i think it's not just dna that
would back that up
there's a lot of made-up theater in
ancient theater too
we're not as sophisticated as we think
we moderate exactly i was gonna say
every generation thinks it invents all
the cool ideas but in fact
they come from the ancient world
i was just going to say i wrote a book
once about ideas of selfhood
in the in the first century and how
there was this dramatic
shift in ideas of selfhood and then i
went to the bookstore and picked up a
book and it said there was a dramatic
shift in ideas of selfhood in the 12th
century
and then i found the same claim made for
basically every century so i just
groaned and gave up yeah
there's only so many books one can write
i guess this is true
but even okay so i guess the last
question on the ana before we move to
china
even if there are many different ways
you can read it and many different
stories
many different implications you can draw
out of it
is there one that sticks out as
especially
meaningful to us here in the beginning
of the 21st century is
while you were reading it translating it
did you go like oh my goodness this
particular aspect really resonates with
me right now
i think what resonated with me were the
constant challenges to authority that
are embedded in the poem
so for example aeneas authority as a
narrator of his own life
is questioned the god's authority as
dispensers
of of destiny and of oracles
is questioned um
[Music]
the um authority of the view
expressed in book six that the romans
like to conquer
but afterwards they spare the conqueror
that that view is questioned with the
final violence of the epic
um and the women whose voices appear to
be discredited
in the epic um are actually
more places where we are invited to
think
about why their voices are suppressed so
just to give you one example um when
anaes
is told by the jupiter that he has to
get the hell out of carthage
um he goes to dido and oh he's sorry he
goes to his men and he says let's
let's start getting ready to leave but
don't say anything to dido because it's
not time yet i don't want her to be
upset
dido finds out and she comes to him and
she says aeneas
you're preparing to leave carthage and
you never told me you you lied to me
you told me you were going to stay here
and he says i never lied to you
i always told you i was going to leave
but that's not true
and in fact when jupiter sends the
warning to aneas
he says you know what aeneas is planning
on staying in carthage
this is not going to be allowed so we
have to go down down to earth and warn
him
so virgil makes it clear in other words
that what dido is saying even though
she's rebuffed by
aeneas is true the woman says hey you
lied to me and you said you'd stay with
me and you said you wouldn't leave me
and the man says don't make up this crap
i never said any of that
but the poem shows us that actually
she's right
right even though it doesn't allow enes
to say he's
she's right gaslighting yeah
cast lighting an ancient very ancient
case of gaslighting
yeah when you hire a new person you
might pick someone brilliant who
elevates your company to
unprecedented heights or you might get
someone you're stuck with for years who
you really don't want to hang around
with
that's why indeed.com is so helpful
indeed.com is the hiring site
that helps you find quality candidates
with indeed instant match
indeed searches through the millions of
resumes in their database to help show
you great candidates instantly
so you can do the part you really need
faster meeting and hiring great people
with indeed there are no long-term
contracts you can pause your account at
any time and you only pay for what you
need
and with instant match you get a list of
great candidates with zero weight
so if you want your quality short list
passed you need indeed and right now our
listeners get a free 75.00 credit
to upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape this is indeed's best offer
available anywhere
get a free 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through march 31
terms and conditions
apply it is amazing
as you say all these things how many
ideas we think of as more or less modern
are prefigured and things like this is
this because
is this is this reflection of the fact
that uh the classics have had this
enormous
impact on us or is it really just a
rediscovery i mean are we sort of seeped
in uh the ideas that were set down by
the ancient greeks and romans
you know sean that's an excellent
question and i think that yes
western civilization whether or not we
realize it
has been very much shaped by the ideas
in our literary and philosophical past
and i'll i didn't realize this as well
until i started looking at the chinese
reception of the classics and in fact
the reason
i turned my gaze on china was because i
said what you just said
let's say we've been as it were sitting
in a bathtub
with these texts for 2000 years and
we're so familiar with them
that we we are interpreting within a a
kind of closed
box what would happen if i looked
outside the west
to see what the classics looked like
there and i learned some very
interesting things
so for example often in the west we
we think of the citizen for example as a
natural category of course there are
citizens
we have been told by plato and aristotle
that rationality is what separates
humans from animals and so we think okay
man is rational and that's what
separates him from animals
um we have a whole bunch of inherited
assumptions that we don't see as
assumptions
until we compare them with other
traditions so just to give a few
examples
um the chinese word for citizen
wasn't actually developed until 1898.
why because the chinese dynasty had no
citizens
and the concept of citizen was
completely alien to them in confucian
thought
the empire was like a large family it
was the family writ large
you don't have a citizen in a family you
wouldn't have a citizen in an empire
right or you might read um the analytics
confucius analects and see that they're
the highest value
that man is supposed to attain is
something called benevolence
in mandarin ren and um
nobody there talks about rationality is
the most important thing separating
humans from animals or making humans
better or unique
and i started thinking to myself well
why did we pick rationality
i much prefer benevolence i like
benevolence
those kinds of things it just opens your
eyes to things you've taken for granted
that are not taken for granted elsewhere
i mean anyone who has a puppy knows that
you cannot give
humans unique access to benevolence
right i mean
you might argue for rationality that is
so true or the rationality for that
matter i think
animals can reason but that's a whole
other question
very much right another thing that's
really different about china that struck
me vis-a-vis the west
goes back to one of your early questions
sean and that's that
the chinese have huge respect for their
own philosophical tradition
or their own ethical tradition which is
you know
20 more than 2600 years old
so much so that when xi jinping delivers
speeches in public he will often quote
confucius
or mencius or another one of the elderly
sages
and he's even pub there's even a book in
china
called something like xi jinping's
quotations from confucius
and in fact there's two volumes of it
because he quotes confucius and mentions
on the others a lot
and that boggled my mind it boggles
nobody's mind in china it seems normal
of course you would look to the past for
value
right but can you imagine donald trump
quoting
aristotle in his speeches no and leaving
trump aside we just
don't have that kind of attitude towards
our own antiquity
we think of it as dated and distant not
present and valuable
now the interesting thing is that the
chinese don't only feel that way about
their
own classics and by the way when i say
the chinese
i mean politically oriented chinese
intellectuals
i'm not talking about the whole country
so not only do they feel the same way
about their own tradition
they feel the same way about the western
classical tradition
they think it must be a locus of value
because it's old and has stood the test
of time in various ways
so even as many people in the west try
to distance themselves from that
the chinese have embraced it and they
embraced it
already at the end of the qing dynasty
and they embrace it today
they just embrace it differently so what
my book plato goes to china is about
is how the chinese appropriation of our
texts
plato aristotle facilities um the
constitution of athens etc
has changed repeatedly based on the
political situation
in china at the time yeah it's a little
bit uh there's a famous thought
experiment where you say
like if anthropologists from mars
came down and tried to look at humanity
and you know we we try to
do the best we can to take a view from
nowhere and think about
human behavior and so forth but it's
very hard to do because we're embedded
in human behavior but in some sense
when we're looking at how chinese people
just to take the example that you're
concentrating
on think about the ancient
greece and roman cultures uh it is sort
of
a reminder to us that there are
different ways you can
think about these things they're not
logically uh necessary
they're they're very very specific and
contention to their time and place and
and we've adapted them in certain ways
but those adaptations are contingent too
here here i'll give you a great example
that's
um plato's noble lie so what's plato's
noble lie
it's part of socrates vision of the
ideal city
in the republic and in this ideal city
to ensure the loyalty of the citizens
and to make sure that everybody stays in
their own hierarchical
place right from the leaders to the
um the the janitors um
socrates says that one has to practice
a lie a lie has to come down from above
to convince the people that they need to
stay loyal and to stay
in their own social classes and the lie
is that they were all born from the
earth representing already
different standards of humanness they
were the gold humans the silver humans
and the bronze humans
and you have to be whatever kind of
human you were
right so this has disturbed many
thinkers in the west
obviously who see it as a blueprint for
eugenics and a blueprint for a
totalitarian society
and a blueprint for a lot of pretty
creepy stuff
right and the response in the west has
been either
to condemn the noble lie or to try to
reread it in a way that it's harmless
like you know the story about george
washington and the cherry tree
or to try to read it ironically as plato
showing us what we should not do
right but in any case we've struggled
with it right we don't like the noble
lie
uh fast forward to china under xi
jinping and the articles i've read
about the noble lie over the past 20 30
years
in mandarin they think the noble lie is
obvious
right the articles i've read about the
noble lie
say yeah of course people are different
of course society is hierarchical
why would anybody think this is a book
big deal of course the ruler needs to
keep the people happy
of course that's going to necessitate
some lying duh
right that's a chinese response so my
first reaction was wow
they think the noble eye is okay and
then my second response was
wow maybe they're saying that about the
noble lie to
expose the chinese noble lie that the
government expands
and at that point my brain exploded
right right
layers too many levels of thinking yeah
many levels of thought
but the interesting thing is that
they're embracing these ideas and
they're doing
with them whatever it is they need to do
and this
is so different from what was going on
in china after the fall of the qing
dynasty
and also during the 1980s when they
turned to western ancient texts
to support the idea that democracy was a
good or they looked to ancient athens
for that same
reason right um
when leanne when liam titau coined the
word for citizen
in 1898 he'd been doing a lot of reading
of
aristotle in japanese translation and he
got from aristotle the idea that
man is a political animal not just a
member of
an empire like a villager right and this
deeply influenced his thought it's why
he came up with a new word for citizen
it's why he wrote all this stuff about
how the chinese had to learn to become
citizens of a nation
as opposed to being members of the
emperor's family everybody was
yay aristotle democracy and in fact
aristotle doesn't think that democracy
is the best form of government but they
just ignored that
and they borrowed aristotle's authority
to say democracy was the ideal
government
and that they should have democracy of
course that didn't work out there was
civil war then mao zedong came along
certainly no democracy no democracy
there but in the 1980s
when people started pushing back against
the government once again
these western texts became popular as
representing democratic values okay
now look at the present after the
squashing
of the protests at tian unmann square
and now
we have these same classical texts being
read and being
valued but they're being read totally
differently
so um i mentioned the noble lie thumbs
up on the noble lie
um when they look back to athens now
they find ways of criticizing athenian
democracy
um either they criticize it for relying
on slaves
which is true it did but they weren't
talking about this earlier
or they say the athenian citizens were
themselves slaves
they were slaves to the idea of the city
and they had to serve the city
politically interesting twist
um or they say that athens lasted less
than 200 years athenian democracy
and they say ha ha american democracy
isn't even 200 years old
i mean democracy in its fullest form and
um
before it gets to 200 years old it's
going to go you know down the toilet
right that's another chinese prediction
or
there's actually a chinese author called
hoshin
who has argued that the west during the
renaissance
invented the ancient world and all the
renaissance
intellectuals quickly wrote up all the
western classics from antiquity
to pretend that the west had its own
noble past
just as china did so get this and the
renaissance
all these intellectuals are running
around creating antiquity
quickly writing up the anae and the
iliad and the odyssey and aristotle and
all this other stuff
because they're jealous of china i know
i i that was my favorite part of your
book the whole idea that all of the
ancient world is fake news that it was
just invented
uh by fabulists in the renaissance and i
presume this is not a very popular
opinion in china even though it was put
forward by somebody
it's it doesn't have a wide following in
china no a lot of people think this is a
little bit excessive
but the other critiques of athenian
democracy are very broadly
um spread around and a final tactic
that you'll see being used in these
texts on ancient democracy is to say
that the west
has stolen the word democracy
and is hogging it and that democracy is
actually a much broader concept than the
western treatment of the word
and on this telling china is the world's
biggest democracy
right not the u.s and this argument is
made because at the lowest levels of the
chinese bureaucratic system
the chinese villagers do vote for local
village heads
there's voting at the lowest level and
then there's exams later
and there's choice by meritocracy or so
they claim
we had a very interesting podcast with
davis to savage about the history of
democracy in the world and
china i mean there are relationships
between the
ancient chinese systems and what we
think of as democracy but they're not
very good ones and he has a whole theory
about why
china and the islamic world did not
become democratic and mostly because
their institutions were too strong that
the people couldn't sort of take over
whereas in europe the institutions were
so weak
that people could eventually just demand
power and get it
that's really interesting um and i think
that must be part of the explanation
i would add other things such as um in
uh
cultural values that have been passed
down from generation to generation that
people don't really question
like the confucian ethic that um the
good of the state
or the the well-being of the state is
more important than the well-being of
the individual
which not many westerners would
necessarily agree with right we say
lower our taxes
they say let's make china strong right
two different things
exactly let me just back up a little bit
because um
i want to also put this in context i
want to get back to the noble law and
democracy and things like that but uh
you we just talked about how you
translated
the anaid from latin to modern english
and now you're reading text in mandarin
so you basically had to learn mandarin
to do this was learning mandarin
first and then you decided to undertake
this project or was
did you learn mandarin to learn about
how the chinese think about the classics
it was a mixture of sean so maybe uh 15
years ago i went to china for the first
time
and so i you know took a little
guidebook with me with some phrases so
that i'd get along
and um i learned the phrase for excuse
me but i didn't know much about chinese
tones
and so when i said excuse me excuse me
in large crowds as i was trying to get
through everybody would jump and look at
me oddly
and i explained this to myself as wow
you know the
more rural chinese in the west have
never heard
westerners speaking such perfect
mandarin and naturally they're
astonished by this
and then i came back to the us and took
chinese and i said to my
chinese professor in chinese 101 excuse
me
and he started laughing and i said
what's wrong and he said
you just said please smell me.
[Laughter]
please smell me and they thought these
americans are so obsessed with hygiene
and rather than run away you said i got
to dig into this further
exactly so then i became really
interested in in tonal languages
and um i also wanted at the same time to
see how the chinese were reading the
classics so these two interests came
together
and i started the long and arduous road
of of trying to learn mandarin
i'll tell you this i took mandarin for
straight eight years at the university
of chicago
and although as a actual undergraduate i
had been a fairly good
undergraduate i was now the class dunce
repeat oh it was so hard and maybe my
brain is just too old
but i have to repeat every year i
repeated year one twice you're two twice
you're three twice and you're four twice
and uh
i think i ended up getting a c for the
last exam so
i am no mandarin genius let's put it
that way
well but it's so let me ask a similar
question to what we started
with about asking about why the western
classics are important and
you i think you made a case i don't want
to use the word exceptionalism
unironically but you did try to say that
there is something
specific that the those classics give us
so
is there something about the chinese
reaction to those western classics that
is specifically interesting or is it
just an example
of another culture reacting to the
western classics
it's a great question i'm going to push
back a little bit on the term
exceptionalism
because i think that many cultures have
classics
that reward close and thoughtful
readings
um but i'm sorry just to be just to be
super clear i was
i was using exceptionalism in terms of
the role of those texts within our
tradition
not uh vis-a-vis other traditions if you
know what it is okay i see
got it that's different than harry
potter yeah
can you repeat your original question
right so
i'm wondering so if we think that you
know there's something about the ancient
greek and latin uh
texts that makes them a little bit
different than modern young adult novels
um and you asked this very interesting
question
how are they being received in china
could you have asked the same question
about how they're being received
in japan or india or whatever or is
there something
some specific reason to think about the
chinese reaction
um i think every country would be
different
china interests me because its main
internal debate
is really about the value of democracy
or
the lack of value of democracy that is a
thing upon which the leadership is very
focused
and many of the classical texts we talk
about
at least superficially seem to endorse
values that are um actually um
full of meaning for the chinese like the
example of a hierarchical society
right in in plato's republic or
um the idea that um
[Music]
um the country is more important than
the citizen i'm trying to think of
that's really an idea
in antiquity and and maybe not but you
know in pericles funeral oration
certainly athens is more important than
the individual athenian
so i think there's a sense in which
china is primed
to have an interesting discussion with
western classical texts
because of that political circumstance
that that makes sense and also maybe it
makes sense that china has this
very long quasi-continuous history where
they have their classics confucius being
sort of the plato of china if we want to
really
vulgarize things a little bit and so
there is a natural
uh comparison to be drawn absolutely and
i was reading
um another contemporary chinese article
actually this was this was a book um by
a chinese intellectual called
by tong dong and it's called
um against political equality
the confucian case just came out and
um the author's name is tong dong bai or
in chinese we put the last name first by
tong dong and it's a very
interesting book um one of the claims it
makes at the end
which is a claim that um i think
many americans would feel absolute
horror at
is that early american democracy
as envisaged by the founding fathers
was actually somewhat like a confucian
state
only not as good as a confucian state
and
it was a flawed confusion state but
unfortunately instead of getting closer
to a confucian state
the americans have continued to fall
away from those early ideals and now
we're stuck with this
modern form of democracy which by would
argue
actually does not work as well as the
confucian state
and i'm not here to endorse that or to
argue with it i'm just here to say
gosh what an interesting claim well and
look at what he's basing it on he's
basing it on a reading of plato
he takes plato as the ideal and then he
shows that the confusion ideal is better
than the platonic ideal
and he bases his argument partially on
that we might say
well why on earth is he arguing with
plato right plato is 2500 years old
why isn't he arguing with examples of
modern democracy
he does that too but i think it's
quintessentially
um revealing of how the chinese value
antiquity
that a chapter of his book uh against
political equality
would be devoted to plato
is there i mean presumably westerners
have commented on confucius
and lao tzu and other ancient chinese
thinkers but is it
comparable like do we get a similar
amount of comparison or are the chinese
more fascinated by
plato and aristotle than we are by
ancient chinese thinkers
the former the chinese are more
fascinated by our ancient thinkers than
we are with theirs
because the people who work on confucius
and laozi and these uh intellectual
figures from early china
they are academics right and they write
books and they talk to their students
and um they are very deeply enmeshed in
this material
but material doesn't really leave the
ivory tower right
so the man in the street does not read
articles in the newspaper in the new
york times
about the problem with confucius say
right
but in china our classical texts
are considered um worthy of interest at
the public level
especially when they've been
appropriated to pervade
chinese uh thoughts or ideologies
and so you will see articles in in
chinese daily newspapers
about the western classics yeah
you will not get that in usa today any
commentary on confucius as far as i can
tell
no commentary on confucius in usa today
i've i've looked long and hard but have
yet to find it
and it's interesting that you highlight
uh democracy
as an issue that was there in ancient
athens and the chinese care about that
makes perfect sense right for modern
political reasons
but um when you mention this sort of
individual
versus state thing i recently did a
podcast with joe henrich i don't know if
you're familiar with his work he's uh
anthropologist psychologist who studies
what art called
weird societies and weird psychology
weird being the acronym for western
educated industrialized rich democratic
i've heard that yeah yeah so he tries to
make the point that not only are these
weird societies different but they're
not or not only are
all of our psycho psychology studies
done on them
but we are outliers we are not you know
in the middle of the distribution of
whatever set of um
characteristics you want you want to put
people under and this
so to me rather than democracy versus
uh you know a more centralized state
this idea that you have brought up
of individuals versus communities
seems to be the more central difference
to me like the
the thing that is different as far as i
can tell in my very very limited
knowledge of these things
about the western tradition is centering
it on
individual people and if you go back to
confucius etc that's just not there is
that a fair reading you think
um well confucius has individual
disciples
with whom he talks and so forth but the
idea
that your your um
the idea that the best political system
is
focused upon the individual and the
individual's right to vote and the
individual's right
to liberty and so far so forth those
just really
aren't embedded in confucian thought as
you might expect
i was just going to say that there was
an interesting uh editorial piece
published in the new york times by a
chinese venture capitalist
several years ago and it argued
that contemporary america was subject to
exactly the same flaws that
facilities had pointed to in classical
athens
namely that we were too quick to listen
to demagogues
who were promising us what we wanted
rather than thinking about the good of
the state as a whole and looking to the
future and what we were leaving
to later generations right
and according to this author eric lee
this is what brought down athens what
ruined athens
that's also what vicinity says and it's
what eric lee says is happening to the
contemporary u.s
and this actually got published in the
new york times so
that's just another example of looking
to the western classics
to point a finger at the people who's
whose western classics they are
in a way do you think that given the
fact that the chinese have
uh what we would consider a pretty
intimate ongoing relationship with
their classics do you think that makes
them exaggerate the extent to which a
typical westerner cares about our
classics
absolutely they um this is something i
made clear
right at the beginning of of plato goes
to china which is that
because they have that intimate
connection to their own past they think
we do
and several chinese intellectuals have
said
if you want to understand the west you
have to read their classics first
otherwise you won't understand them
because their classics have shaped who
they are
and meanwhile here in the west we're
going oh you know the classics not so
relevant to us
so they're taking the opposite view if
you look at a chinese textbook it'll
even say something
like american democracy came from
athenian democracy
no further explanation right so um
they are very sure that there's a value
a political and diplomatic value to
studying
our ancient texts precisely because they
think that we are shaped by them as much
as they are
shaped by theirs maybe it's true and we
just don't see it i don't know right
yeah so maybe like we alluded to earlier
it's
the influence of our classics are so
much in the background of the air we
breathe that we
really are being influenced by them in
ways that we don't know ourselves
exactly it's like that old joke about
the fish you know this one
i do but tell it anyway okay so it's not
my joke
it's the joke of a novelist speaking
who's since passed away speaking at a a
college
uh convocation um i'm trying to remember
his name he's very well known david
foster wallace
yes david foster wallace so david foster
wallace tells this joke that i just find
incredibly
um meaningful he says these two young
fish are swimming along
and an older fish passes them going in
the opposite direction
and the older fish says hey boys how's
the water
and the two fish say it's great sir and
they keep on swimming
and then one of them turns to the other
after the big fish has swim away and
says
what the hell is water and that's how i
feel about
you know culture it's very hard to
separate oneself from it
well yeah and as we said like if we
think that westerners
have this have ideals of you know the
individual
and maybe democracy or at least the idea
that
some authority for the state comes in
some way directly or indirectly from
people
those are values that maybe arguably we
get from the classics
not not in a straight line path but we
got them from there and they might not
be shared everywhere
exactly i would i would really agree
with that
and so how so given that you and i uh
are largely westerners i'm more
westerner than you are i've never lived
anywhere other than the united states
and you've lived all over
but um have you learned about
what water is by studying the opinions
of these people who did not grow up
swimming in water
yes i i feel like i have been
plopped into different waters at
different times of my life when i was a
child i spent a lot of time in southeast
asia
my mother is iranian my first language
was not english
et cetera et cetera et cetera and i came
to the us as an adult
already kind of fully formed but even so
i do
have those same kind of inherited from
the western classics values maybe
because i've studied the classics
for so long um um
yeah i think it is possible to stand
outside your water
but it's hard and being immersed in all
things chinese has really been helpful
to me
in that regard i've founded an education
a very interesting and valuable
education and i think it's also enabled
me
maybe to look with a little bit more
distance on how we're currently talking
about
our classics as you know the classics
have become kind of a
a bone of political contention
in many in many educational contexts
where people wonder if they should be
taught at all
and when i say classics i don't just
mean you know plato and aristotle or the
innate i also mean
shakespeare and you know chaucer and the
members of the
the white elite canon as it were and
the the debate tends to get um binarized
in that there's there's a presenter's
side that thinks we should read texts
that reflect our own values
and that solidify those values such as
our values are today
right and then there's this kind of
maybe i don't want to say elitist but
maybe more traditional group that says
these are great and complex and rich
texts and we should learn
from them but i would prefer to tread a
middle ground
and not so much discuss whether we
should
only read texts that reflect our values
or
only read texts that are in the the
western tradition
i think we should use these texts to
discuss
our values and to discuss any set of
values
and they enable us to do this because
they don't come out and just baldly
endorse something they're way more
complex
and beautiful and deep and and
value questioning than that right it's a
it's an invitation
to converse and dialogue and think about
things rather than
people handing us the answers right and
i think
it's not people handing us the the
ethically correct answers of the present
day
it's not people handing us the more
elitist values
of era's past it's a place for
reflection
and i think the task of a good teacher
is to bring that out and i think
many if not most teachers do do that
i mean i can't imagine somebody who
would
only read the merchant of venice
to say that shakespeare was an
anti-semite i mean that's
not the most interesting thing about
that text and it's also
frankly i'm not sure if it's even
defendable
is there anything specific that you
would say that now that you've been
reading all these chinese scholars
uh about the western classics which
you've been an expert on for many years
is there anything specific that you said
like oh my goodness i've been wrong
about the classics for all this time
or at least i maybe i have a different
perspective now great question
no that's not what i got what i got was
oh my goodness
i and everybody else including prior
generations and the chinese and
everybody
tends to see in these texts what they go
looking for
and so the texts are almost a mirror
right and you know if the chinese find
their values in the text and we find our
values in the text and prior generations
found their values in the text maybe we
need to be
self-conscious about um all those
differences and and how they're possible
i did want to mention uh you have a
little interlude in your book uh
straussian interlude which uh resonated
with me
leo strauss political philosopher uh
who spent a lot of time at the
university of chicago but i got to know
him long before
most people did because when i was an
undergraduate in the 80s one of my
political science professors was a
died in the world in the world
straussian uh and that was before
australians had sort of you know
popped up into the popular uh
conversation as much as they have so i
was just
very amused to see that there are
chinese straussians of of all things
and maybe why don't you try to explain
to us what that means in this context to
be a straussian and how it has to do
with
reading the classics absolutely so the
chinese straussians
it's mostly two prominent people in
their their pupils
um seem to like strauss for the
following reasons
one he values antiquities values
not the values of modernity two he
claims that
philosophical texts need to be read for
a secret message
that is not available to the ordinary
person
and um three his position on democracy
is very much
up for grabs it's unclear if he's pro or
anti
and um because of these three features
chinese straussians can basically
interpret
our philosophical texts as straussians
saying they see a message that's not
evident to everybody
and the message that they see is usually
a message
that ends up supporting in one way or
another
the um the chinese state in its current
manifestation
right yeah it's pretty amazing so you
could actually read virgil
and come out the other end seeing that
virgil was in favor of xi jinping
right um the other thing that this lets
them do
is um is it lets them adopt one of
strauss's
main points or main arguments which is
that it's dangerous to be a philosopher
because philosophers are interested in
truth
and not political affiliations and
therefore
the philosopher cannot speak openly and
he's always in danger
that's another rationale for reading
esoterically reading for the hidden
message
um and the chinese philosophers
who read this like this not because
they're in danger
they're not but because they like to
think of
themselves i think as having a really
important voice in the state one that
should be listened to
and one that can guide the state even if
the state is a little bit wary of it
so unlike the strauss the real
straussian philosophers
they're not hiding away and speaking
speaking esoterically
they're speaking openly but they're
saying that they got what they're saying
out of esoteric readings of western
classics
well it's fascinating to me because you
know you put forward this idea
that there are many different ways to
read and to get things out of the
classics whether they're in the western
tradition of chinese tradition or
whatever
which sort of bears a superficial
similarity to this particular straussian
point of esoteric readings but
there's a crucial difference that if i
understand correctly the straussians
want to say
there is an a sort of surface exoteric
reading and then there's a deeper
esoteric reading and the esoteric
reading
is the right one there is only one right
reading but it's only available
to us uh really deep straussian thinkers
that's right so is that is that what the
is that the attitude that the chinese
strategies are taking on that they have
seen things in these texts that
the naive readers don't get definitely
definitely
in their case the naive readers are the
western readers though
and then the question always is where do
you stop right i mean i i don't know how
self-reflective the strategies are about
this but
uh what you tend to see is people
reading
meanings into text that they want to
find there and saying aha this is the
esoteric meaning and i don't know what
the criteria are for saying like
when am i right and when am i wrong
about that it's a really complicated
question
the chinese strassians actually reject
the idea that they represent a school
they say strauss is not an ism strauss
is just the way things are
right so they would deny that they're
distorting the texts
at all theirs is simply the correct
reading
um i would say one difference in this
issue of the malleability of these texts
sean is that the strategians basically
always get the same reading
no matter what the text is that they
read and the reading at least on the
chinese side
is not only that the philosopher and the
politician can't speak to each other
because
the politician needs to sh to shut out
certain truths and to
represent things to the public in a way
that the philosophers might not
agree with but also um
they get out of these texts a political
justification for the way things are in
china
right and so it's a very narrow form of
reading
whereas the malleability the whole point
about the malleability of these texts is
that they lend themselves to all sorts
of different readings
so you we i would push back against the
school that says there's only one
possible reading
yeah exactly and it sort of brings us
back this is a good sort of way to wrap
up
because we started with the noble lie
right and
uh and i helped me out here with the
noble lie a little bit because
here's plato saying that on the one hand
we should tell people
that there are you know categories of
humanity gold silver bronze or whatever
and they're built in
but he's saying that we should tell
people that like it's very clear that
it's a lie
and so exactly he's exposing the lie by
saying let's tell a lie
and did was so how intentional was i
ever it's like saying by the way the
following is propaganda
and then saying it and then you should
believe it i mean but plato's not
not a dummy what you know was was he
expecting that only the philosopher
kings would read his book or
what what was going on or was he was he
just having fun with us
sean there are thousands and thousands
of philosophers who will give you
thousands of different
different answers but i do think it's
interesting how parallel that is to the
chinese articles that say
of course we need a local lie noble eyes
are good we want the government to lie
to us
so they're effectively saying we see the
government lying to us
and the whole point of the noble lie is
you're not supposed to know it's a lie
you're supposed to think it's the truth
about the way things are so on the
chinese side too
it has that extremely bizarre um
self-exposing uh value
and this is uh it's very much in keeping
with this theme of
meta fiction and uh works that are
commenting on themselves
in some way right and so i mean you're
you're persuading me
i'm a soft target here but uh you're
persuading me that the way to approach
these texts
is more as a a dynamical engagement in
conversation rather than
searching for the one fixed meaning at
some layer that's going to win out over
all the others
oh my god yes
[Laughter]
well that is the perfect place to end it
never happened before that a podcast
guest
has listened to something i said and
said oh my god yes so i think i'm gonna
declare victory
uh with that shady barge thank you so
much for being on the mindscape podcast
thank you sean i've enjoyed it
[Music]
do
[Music]
you